welcome back to the Rich Eisen show
we've all enjoyed her work in three
mission Impossibles the first true
detective films like Kiss Kiss Bang Bang
Gone Baby Gone
Patriots day and more and now available
for streaming of the last couple of days
on Netflix or new show Messiah good to
see you Michelle how are you I'm well
I'm very well I always loved having a
big tenor a fellow Big Ten individual
sitting here you are from the great
state of Iowa yeah kind of mind this a
little bit the last time yeah so just
growing up Iowa Hawkeye football was
always on in your household 100%
especially with older brothers I mean
I'd probably okay just by default if I
tried to change the channel yeah pretty
much yeah
when I first went to Michigan the name
Chuck long was a four-letter word yes he
beat my you know Jim Harbaugh the
current coach and a quarterback at the
time yeah he beat like an undefeated
Michigan team and Chuck long was a
four-letter word on the campus blast
from your past there sure so are you is
your family still into Iowa football yes
a hundred percent it was a big win for
us the other day yeah that was us we
smoked them and by the way we really
needed to because our performance at the
Rose Bowl
a few years ago was just it was
appalling yeah it was really substandard
right so to at least show the Southern
California audience what they what they
can do and look like yeah that's exactly
right
just again in this day and age where
things gets you know so if you will 21st
century whatever just go into that
Stadium it's it's kind of like a blast
in the past did you grow up and that's
team you never go to that stage yeah
yeah and I think now especially now what
they do you know then during the
halftime and they do the when they know
it's so special it makes me so proud and
you know there's been so many great
things that have come out of just
specifically that but yeah it's I'm very
much a proud you know I went in and
specifically a proud Hawkeye did you
ever play sports you ever get anything
you know I'm actually I didn't find my
athleticism it's such a funny weird just
word to say and so later in life I was
really awkward growing up and I and I
just didn't have any confidence
whatsoever
playing any sports but I was a hell of a
fan I was always in the stands rooting
everybody on but now I love to get out
there and play and do any kind of sport
there is or any kind of outdoor activity
so so yeah it just it just took me a
while to get there so it wasn't growing
up in Iowa you heard noises from the
cornfield and just got a little bit
concerned scared of sports because there
is no whispering from the corners just
like you know that was my brother's
territory you know I had old her
brothers so that was their thing and it
was just something that I never sort of
you know I never really got into you
know yeah Michelle Monaghan here on the
Rich Eisen show okay so also I think you
mentioned last time you were here that
you're from a Cubs family too because I
mean that's oh yeah that's essentially
that's kind of like a through-line in
many ways because the Cubs have a
triple-a affiliate in Iowa and just I
was right next door
Illinois it's true that the first time I
ever went to a city it was to see a
Chicago Cubs don't go to Wrigley Field
yeah and then and as a result of having
not seen the city and they won I
remember the morning surprisingly at
that time well they had like Rick
Sandberg and there was like you know
back all those great players and but
that's when I decided I want to go to
college in Chicago and so I went I ended
up going to Columbia College in Chicago
but that was like my first taste of a
big city oh you're fat your your family
took you to Wrigley Field yeah it's all
Chicago yeah I saw like buildings I grew
up in a town I was like oh wow these are
skyscrapers oh my god I want to live
amongst these and not the cows
understand you wound up doing a cat I
wound up going to college there and then
from there I moved to New York because
you know if I wanted bigger skyscrapers
and and then from and then in New York
that's when I started acting I
discovered acting and how you got your
break is that that's essentially how I
got my break you know when I was in
Chicago in order to put myself through
school I modeled I did like Montgomery
Ward's I did all the target ads I did
all that so do that during the day and
then I would go to school at night
and that's kind of how I got myself
through school I studied journalism
though you did yeah I studied journalism
that's what I wanted to do I thought I
wanted
to do like what like a reporter
investigative journalism yeah reporting
like 60 minutes yeah you know it's
interesting we were always a big current
events family and we watched the news we
talked about the news constantly and I
think also when you come from such a
small town such a small place you're
always constantly kind of looking beyond
you like what's life you know like
beyond this little pocket here and so
when I went to Chicago and I saw that I
was like I saw a real opportunity to be
able to kind of go to school there and
be able to put myself through school and
kind of explore the greater part of the
world what would that person who what
would that Michelle Monaghan who was
modeling to get through school say if
she knew the current Michelle Monaghan
Instagram account with one point one no
what I was always so determined I you
know I always felt very fortunate
because my folks always said I could do
my brothers as well you could just just
work hard put your mind to it you can do
whatever you want so I always felt
really supported and even if like I
failed at anything I always felt support
I could always go back to my folks I
mean my parents were always rooting me
on so I I would say I would say probably
say thank you to your parents a little
bit more you know because they have been
incredibly instrumental in my success
you're talking to somebody who my start
I got I went to the Medill School of
Journalism I wanted to go but it was so
damned expensive I had to settle for
Columbia
you didn't model without your say I
actually did I strained high school
games in like Wheeling yeah and
Schaumburg and out for the Chicago
Tribune
that just make a few bucks but my
parents were like you know go ahead load
up on student loans we've got your back
yeah especially when I got out of there
my first job was in Redding California
doing the nightly sports well for I'm
not kidding you 650 an hour
I believe it it's the lowest paying
degree coming out of school and I didn't
I didn't even graduate I left right
before my senior year because of
specifically that realizing after having
done internships and things like that
right that I was gonna have to go back
to Iowa and essentially be a one-man
band
I was like no man like I don't know what
to do I'm not going to Iowa just more
I'll just move further east really
something works out there you know and
then obviously acting did but yeah my
parents were always so supportive of as
well so I know exactly at real Monaghan
on Twitter at Michelle Monaghan on
Instagram Michelle Monaghan here on the
Richardson show let's talk Messiah um
because it is cool it is cool yeah did
you shoot some of it much of it all of
it in the actual Middle East we did we
did so we shot a good portion of it we
shot for about six weeks there maybe
close to two months okay we shot the the
show it takes place in in Texas
Washington DC Syria Israel and Jordan
and we shot Jordan for Syria and Israel
and God I got to tell you that's like
one of the most you know the one of the
biggest privileges that I enjoy probably
is an actors getting to travel and going
to places that I normally wouldn't have
put on my list of Jo right and you know
creatively practically speaking you know
when you're you know shooting a show the
scope and of this you know with all
these various points of view you need to
be shooting in that exact place so that
was really helpful in terms of creating
the character and the story and you can
really feel the production
you and the scope of the show no doubt
about that and then again you know there
is no Messiah
I don't believe going on right now but I
mean you talk about the Middle East
being in the headlines and it could not
be more real it's or if you will scary
Iran and I'm wondering what you learned
did you learn anything through this
whole process it's interesting you know
I mean what I learned through the course
of it and I think you know our show
runner has done such a great job and you
know really you know he's the creator of
the show and he came up with Astoria so
intricately woven you know and it's
basically up for the audience of the
viewers to kind of unravel the truth
right and so depending on where you're
from whatever walk of life you've led
and belief system that you inhabit you
will have a different take away you know
then the person next to your your your
take away is probably gonna be different
than mine and and as my husband's was
different than mine and so what I
learned is that you know really
ultimately you know having been able to
travel there and I met some good friends
there I had some Jordanian people that
I'd met that take had taken me in when I
was there solo at Thanksgiving last year
and and I spent the you know the day
with them and we're all really
ultimately no matter where we are what
corner of the earth whatever language
you speak whatever religion you practice
that we're more alike than we are
different and we really all just want
the health safety and freedom you know
and I think what's important about this
show is that you know you're gonna walk
away saying okay he's a con artist or
all these characters are searching for
something the Messiah the Messiah a
writer or you know he never says he's
the Messiah it's ever if he holds a
mirror to every character and it's a
reflection of them and what he what you
want him to be to you so I want him to
be a con artist because I believe he's a
Conners whereas you know there are other
characters in the story that are
searching for salvation and they want
him to save him or hope so depending on
what you are and it's so it's a it
provokes a conversation and so that's
what I love and these divisive times is
you know people sharing their
perspective
and having the opportunity to put
ourselves in someone else's shoes across
the world well you're great in it
everybody's great in it and it's the
story's terrific and what a time to be
on Netflix as well right I mean all
right so before I let you go I'd like to
play celebrity true or false like
they'll twofold you have the drop here
for michelle monaghan celebrity true or
false
[Music]
first up for michelle monaghan on Rich
Eisen shows celebrity true or false true
or false you hold a class a driver's
license driver's license which permits
you to legally operate an 18-wheel truck
and 18 wheelers formerly held but yes I
went to truck driving school I played a
truck female trucker and I went I'm in
trucker and trucker yeah I drove that
Grapevine 18-wheeler double-clutch you
know come on yeah oh yeah parallel
parked it well you have to in order to
get your license what's that like
it's absolutely nerd it's mind-bending
is the best way that I can explain
absolutely mind-bending I must ask ya
when you attempted or successfully yes
yes let's just say that successfully
pulled off the parallel parking of an
18-wheeler was there an actual vehicle
in front and behind you like that you
would have it's basically like a loading
dock but you have to get it yeah yeah
that's not parallel parking no totally
different but I had it for a few years
because I got it for the movie because I
was like unless I try it I'm able to
actually drive this yes this thing that
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna do the roll
and so I proved it to myself and I did
it it was great and it was so
nerve-racking but I ended up letting the
the license go because if you get pulled
over for any fine whatsoever it's like
triple triple the triple to find it
wasn't worth it I have no intention of
I just wanted it to be like I could my
brothers and my dad have theirs right so
I just wanted to do a Mike on like yo I
can drive truck now and brother said
yeah but you're still ugly okay second
thing second aspect here celebrity true
or false with michelle monaghan true or
false you won multiple blue ribbons as a
hog wrestler at age 13 I did I did but I
would say I wouldn't say multiple I
would say twice two years in a row it's
multiple okay okay it's a thing I don't
even know if they still do it anymore
it's actually now when I think back on
it it's terrible but it is like a
Buchanan County and our you know summer
fair Winthrop I all right I Robert
gallery yes yes you went to school I
went to I went to high school with him
Michelle Monaghan and Robert gallery on
the same high school yearbook is always
saying yeah and there was only 38 people
in my high school right small world
assume he was a mountain of an
individual yes Matt well the whole
family was really I mean they were all
amazing athletes so incredible athletes
great family really nice you know very
world you know yeah yeah human beings
yeah and then again oh you've already I
guess dumbest you already hit this you
were one semester away from a journalism
degree yes it's screwing them yeah
exactly and your first acting gig was
one this show called young Americans it
lasted a season on the CW network but it
allowed VZW sure but I didn't have an
agent at that time so I was able to cold
call some people and I and I knocked on
my agents stores 20 years ago she's
still Meijin today I said I don't know
what I'm doing but I got a job and I
said I promise I'll work hard and she
said I believe you let's give it a shot
okay so then who's crazier Harrelson or
Makani which ones close that's that's a
tough one man they're there yet they're
just they're just two peas in a pod
I mean we've we've had we haven't had
woody Heron to get off the island of
hawaii yeah that's true I've been told
I've been told by mutual friends and
other agents whatever like I think you
would yeah that's what I've been told
and I will take that to the bank
Bob will next time I see him I'll tell
Joe but I've been told he's got to get
him off the island why we've had Matthew
McConaughey here several times he is I
mean it's great when you meet somebody
and and they are as you would expect
hundred-person they're down to earth and
all of that yes and I just don't know if
he really does talk to himself while
driving
Masaya go stream it on Netflix right now
and follow michelle monaghan again on
twitter at real Monaghan and be one of
the 1.1 million on Instagram at Michelle
Monaghan thanks for coming on here thank
you
you know that appreciate that and in
television audience I'm gonna open
residual checks with you great let's do
it that's when we come back on the radio
audience will take your phone calls and
has Jason Garrett is there any news on
that front Chris after the break okay
that's after the break right here on the
Rich Eisen all right one more segment
with Michelle Monaghan cuz we quite
honestly can't quit you I've been doing
this of late with the celebrity guests
and I would like to open residual checks
with you and I think this has a drop as
well correct
[Music]
he's mad okay very good I have six
envelopes here which one shot oh my gosh
let's get sure yeah yeah lean in and
you've chosen envelope number five
michelle monaghan has chosen that the
what's the first residual check you got
oh my gosh the first one would have been
four oh god a secret deodorant
commercial commercial but the check that
I still get today was from a movie that
I was cut out of which Constantine and I
remember I got that job and they ended
up cutting me out of the film and I
thought I was gonna have to pay them
back because I was such a newbie my age
and I was like wait they're cutting me
out of the movie issues again it's okay
don't worry they just think they had to
cut the storyline has nothing to do with
you and I was like do I have do I have
to like return the money yeah she was
like no so now every time I open up that
chick check there's a quick blip of me
in the last final moments of that movie
that for whatever reason they've gotta
send me that check and every time I get
that check I get the best feeling that
comes over this was a leather heads
check cuz I got cut out of that movie oh
right and I still get it's not it's from
like mic which is that oh no I don't
that was at Disney's the kid my bad here
we go
ladies and gentlemen 7.56
[Music]
number three here we go one more time
for one more
do you still get law and order yes I
still get law and order
I mean it's it's it's basically it's
like looking at your resume isn't it you
reflect back you're like oh my and they
are there for like seven bucks this and
that oh my god just from the puppy-dog
palace I just did
go away Michelle a hundred and fifty
three bucks for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app